how this goes Bob De Niro one of the
most you know talented actors of Our
Generation has a baby at 79 that's news
and so the first time people see you out
in public that generates a lot of
conversation how did you take that what
was your reaction to the headlines
some of the things they said it takes a
lot of pretty thick skin so I was kind
of I would see a lot of oh they're so
tired or they're this or they're that or
they look somber or they're not happy
and it was a little frustrating to see
sometimes and then every time I
criticize you too tired to smile like
you said that you don't look happy it
just says you don't know what's going on
in people's lives is my way yeah I'm
like mind your own business a bit and if
you want to say something don't always
attach what you think in your mind is
the story you don't know us you don't
know what happened in somebody's life